there are two important data points that
we can consider to help us think about
how influencers can affect voter turnout
the first is that we know that age
makeup of the electorate is changing so
by the next presidential cycle gen Z and
Millennials are expected to make up
nearly half of the U.S voting population
the other piece that we need to consider
is just how many gen Z and Millennials
are using Tick Tock and what they're
using Tick Tock for tick tock has become
a top destination for news Pew recently
found that more than a quarter of Young
Americans under the age of 30 regularly
get their news there and so between that
and the fact that creators have in you
know there's some creators that have
enormous followings on this platform
many of them can actually draw more
eyeballs and engagement than new set
lists across the board any organization
would tell you that if you have a global
Mega star like somebody like a Taylor
Swift telling everybody go out and get
registered and make sure you have a plan
to go vote next week many people are
going to register register and micro
influencers who have very small but very
loyal very attached very dedicated
followings they can be just as powerful
at moving the needle especially in
places that are Battleground States and
we even know just in speaking to some of
the non-profits that are working on get
out the vote around the midterms that
they have seen in recent election cycles
that having influencers get involved it
just dramatically increases the number
of voter registrations that they have so
Rock the vote which is one of the groups
that we spoke to they have teamed up
with in influencer marketing firm that
they worked with ahead of the 2020
presidential election and they said that
that past collaboration helped Drive
roughly 200 000 new voter registrations
during that cycle they really build
themselves as nonpartisan and they
really focus on driving the point that
they are not out there trying to tell
you who to vote for they're just out
there trying to get you to vote in the
first place it's really difficult for
them even though they build themselves
as non partisan to disentangle
themselves from leaning one way or the
other so for example you know you look
at the influencer guidelines that they
sent to all their creators ahead of the
election they have language and they're
saying you have the opportunity this
election cycle to elect leaders who can
tackle climate change and who can
protect your access to abortion and who
can you know make sure that voting is
protected and things like that and I
think that you know anybody reading
between the lines who understands kind
of which way these kinds of issues tilt
would think those are more Progressive
causes it's a really really tricky line
for a lot of these creators and
influencers to tow because a lot of them
have uh audiences that fall across the
political Spectrum there's one
influencer for example who I was going
to speak with for the story that we put
out who has six million followers in the
State of Florida he only would speak to
Forbes on the condition that there were
no political questions asked another
creator that we spoke to for the story
who's also working with rock the a vote
he explained that he has put too much
time and too much effort into building
trust with his audience and building his
brand that it's not worth it to him to
tell people this is who you have to vote
for he's just more interested in saying
Hey I want you to get out and vote and I
want you to go do whatever whatever it
is that you're going to do but he said
that many influencers sort of know
better than to go any further than that
I spoke to somebody who used to serve in
the Obama White House she was direct
former director of digital rapid
response and now she is helping crooked
media run their vote save America
campaign ahead of the midterms and her
view was that this is telling people to
to go vote is becoming something of a
check the box that I think we're
influencers it's becoming kind of
performative we see that kind of
behavior around many other big social
and political causes that said there's
also organizations that see that there
should be some sort of a middle ground
between putting out partisan messaging
versus putting out non-partisan
messaging and gen Z for change which is
one of the groups you spoke to for the
story they're one of the groups doing
that so they have sort of in a 60 40
split they were explaining of putting
out nonpartisan messaging the kinds of
stuff you'd see from rockthevote and
vote.org encouraging people out to the
polls and the other 40 they're very
explicitly throwing their weight behind
or individual members of the leadership
team at least are very explicitly
throwing their way behind specific
candidates saying this is an issue this
is where this person stands on it this
is where that person stands on it which
direction do you want to go in they're
you know being a lot more overt about
the types of people that they're
supporting